ces entrepôts ce sont ceux d' SOS
accessoir le leader français de
l'autoréparation et de la vente de
pièces détachées avec une hausse de 30 à
50 % de la demande chaque année
l'entreprise a déménagé à morpa dans des
locaux de 8000 m car et a investi dans
un système automatisé pour la gestion de
leur
colis mais comment ça marche première
étape le peaking un opérateur prélève et
rassemble les articles d'une commande
dans un bac ce dernier est ensuite
déposé sur les tapis en direction des
tables de colisage les opérateurs
scannent et accolent une étiquette de
support du client et les redépô sur les
tapis qui seront photographiés et pesés
par les
machines à cela s'ens su la formation et
la fermeture des colis redirigés grâce à
leur étiquette vers différentes gardes
des transporteurs ça nous permet de
produire beaucoup plus de colis de faire
face à des grandes variations de volume
à à à produire ça permet bien sûr aussi
une meilleure
productivité dans certains cas une
meilleure qualité et puis un meilleur
confort de travail pour les opérateurs
depuis l'acquisition de cette machine
Olivier de monliiveau l'assure aucun
licenciement n'a été effectué mais les
commandes ell ont explosé l'activité
peut atteindre jusqu'à 8000 expéditions
de colis par
jour